I will be back baby made a bag for my
mommy gave my mother boom redmond Garber
day-off [ __ ] [ __ ]
hello everybody now we are back in this
[ __ ] game I hate it so much never be
tried for hours and died again
[ __ ] hello [ __ ] [ __ ] here we go
again you [ __ ] okay so welcome back to
60 seconds I know it's been a long time
but there has been an update to this
game and no I haven't been Nick I know I
haven't I've never have I can't it's
[ __ ] impossible there's been an
update now their challenge modes which
are super cool I think I have no idea if
they're actually cool or not but I'm
gonna find out very soon so with that
being said and now that the music has
gotten out of the way the really loud
music we're gonna try one of these
challenges how about the holiday collect
item and family members listed below and
make your way to the shelter before time
runs out oh is easy oh I'll get a hat
all I need is a map all I need a map a
suitcase all my family members and then
that's it well that's easy
well that's [ __ ] easy let's do this
[ __ ] do I even have to survive no great
I know it's been a while and I've had
such like the toughest cow but you can i
what oh there we go I was like what
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right damn yeah yeah
but come with me family we've got places
to go hmmm yeah okay so we just need the
map in the suitcase [ __ ] where are they
soup water soup water not that I didn't
need four of those okay where the [ __ ]
is it
okay suitcase there it is whoo we do we
do we do we do what would do it okay
where's the map where's the map where's
the map I'm a map I'm the map buy my map
I'm a [ __ ] map where's the [ __ ]
map there it is it's on the other side
whoa never never ever never ever - BAM
done Wow okay that sounds easy enough
brand it's not bad I shot Brad I got
that that's not bad
where do I get a survive on this one or
am I actually going at a holiday
do I have to survive hey the end
apparently yay woo oh no oh oh oh I won
actually won I didn't win that doesn't
count this is a bunch of [ __ ] I
didn't win well that was fun I got a hat
out of it I think right so honeymoon
flecked items and make your way to the
shelter oh I'll get a beach hat oh I
know these challenges aren't the same as
everything that I actually need but I
want to know what I'm doing okay so I'm
going on an epic honeymoon with my wife
I'm not gonna remember all that am i oh
I'm not gonna remember that oh boy I am
NOT oh good I don't need to remember all
that it's just listed right there fire
axe don't need that don't know why I got
that Glock need that to lock the door so
the kids don't go anywhere yeah okay all
right okay let's get these these these
these playing cards these deadly daily
identify agra these [ __ ] cuttin it
close here cuttin it close couldn't
close where's the stuff nope don't need
the kids definitely don't need the kids
oh boy where's the [ __ ] stuff oh no
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead we're all gonna blow up [ __ ]
where's it put the [ __ ]
No Oh [ __ ] well now I'm dead no
honeymoon for me in the honey it's just
gonna be horrible yeah I know I've seen
that Oh Dolores is down there alone
without her hubby oh hi Dolores hey okay
let's try this again shall we
what the [ __ ] is that the [ __ ] is on the
floor the [ __ ] is that what is on the
floor there that's so cool but probably
not well we don't need bullets that's
for sure oh well we got it anyway welp
we got okay we don't need any of this
this is not what we needed
oh why fall [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
well I broke the game well
well I broke the game well I broke the
[ __ ] game oh boy well good to know ok
ok ok gotta get that gotta get that
gotta get the board get a good cards
gotta get the way I've gotta get the way
where's the way where's the wayfarer
where's that way whew whew
where's that wifey of mine there she is
okay gotta get one more bottle of water
got to get a lot of water we need to
hydrate for all that we're gonna be
doing then we need to find the lock
wherever the hell that is got the
flashlight right here those lock with a
lock with a lock or the house of lock
you got em lock and I'll see the law
cannot see the lock anywhere where's a
good em lock don't [ __ ] on matters well
okay we're out here bye kids have fun
the nuclear apocalypse rowdier not even
close not even close
gun baby oh we're gonna have a good time
oh we're gonna have a real good time
just me and the missus hell yeah oh
that's lovely
that's lovely not gonna help us in the
nuclear winter but that's lovely
okay so those are the only two
challenges available but I know that's
not why you're here and you guys know
that's not why I'm here
there was an update yes but it's also an
excuse for me to try one more time so
that I maybe just maybe just maybe just
maybe have what I need okay I'm not
gonna try a little boy I'm trying on fat
man I have everything that I need it's
gonna be okay right it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be all right
it's gonna be wonderful we're gonna have
good stuff happening one last trial is
one last final try to beat this [ __ ]
game so I just got to get everything get
in the goddamn shelter let not
everything die and then everything is
gonna be a-okay go go go go go go get
get get get get get clickety clackety
clack
Sadusky canoe ski all right get that get
the briefcase get the gas mask your bow
ski okay get this in here get the map
get this dad dead okay good new ski okay
doing good doing good gotta get the
family got to get the family can't get
family when she's there got to get that
and the radio happen okay get a get the
Google you do to you in Little Italy we
got 30 seconds left okay go go go go go
go get you game might as well get you
get go and go and go and go and gone
gone gone gone go go go get Tim and get
Tim and get Tim and get Timmy get Tommy
whole [ __ ] cutting it close coming close
we do not have a lot of food I got to
make food run oh I can make it I can
make it one more run one more run one
more run one more food run food run give
give give give give give give give okay
here we go here we go here we go do we
have time for anything else no we do not
let's go in Wow good yeah again whoa
okay ah boy we got a lot of stuff I
think we got just about everything I'm
not sure what I'm not sure what we got
but I think we got just about everything
this is probably the best bet for us to
be able to get through this we got a lot
get a lot mind you we got a lot huh we
got bullets okay we got bullets out of
the suitcase so that's good because I
did grab the gun we got one more water
we got everyone here so I am going I
forget do you need to ration the
supplies immediately do you need to
ration the supplies right away is every
four days I believe no it's not every
four days because I forgot the Boy Scout
Handbook [ __ ] I'm a dick idiot i'ma
Dickey it I'm an idiot that was the one
thing I have to have oh no oh no I
forgot that oh no oh no oh no oh
no the Boy Scout Handbook is arguably
the most important item in the shelter
as it has many different uses I [ __ ]
up
really really badly Oh No okay well I
[ __ ] up really badly so that is really
bad I am dumb I am dumb I am really
[ __ ] dumb didn't do very good oh boy
we can make it work even in Toronto
question is how do we find a boat to get
there we heard it's the best way to get
to Europe what what what the [ __ ] is he
talking about here well alright let's
prepare for an expedition radio chair oh
all those taxes shall we head out Oh
airdrops
yes give us a Boy Scout Handbook a Boy
Scout Handbook
yeah we just got supplies so we're gonna
give everyone what they need no yeah I
think without the handbook it's every
three days but maybe it's not anymore
because I did not see that in here it
looks fine everyone's fine everyone is
okay everyone's fine you go out there
with gas masks you have a good time go
get him buddy
go get him Teddy Boy wait I forget is
Ted the best one to go out oh no not oh
no Timmy is Timmy's the best scavenger
but Timmy doesn't have the handbook so I
don't have that be good okay could have
sworn we had a huge puddle of water
Oh God a flyed a flood well we need the
radio god dammit oh boy we are not
having a good time here this is about
the worst thing that we could possibly
imagine radio is rescued but the map is
dead regular family has arguments but it
was never as intense as a fight we just
got into no one wants to speak to each
other let's hope this won't last too
long you know what's gonna help
everybody hats hats make everything
better tone it ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha death is imminent for us we are
guy oh we could barely sleep after
arguing let's hope it won't happen again
we always see it away from casinos
gambling dens and the like so when a man
came to our door and told us he used to
be a gambler we're suspicious nope we're
not even gonna try that because I don't
want I don't have anything to do it and
I wouldn't do it anyway Hey
Teddy's back Tanny looks tired you
[ __ ] up the gas mask [ __ ] you dude
come on he didn't get anything Ted
didn't get anything Ted you idiot
god damn it Ted we had the most curious
visit of the day when I was making
galloping sound oh I don't have a map it
got ruined in the [ __ ] Floyd why
didn't we gather any of that water huh
why didn't we get any that water huh
all right Sidney you outside you bring
everything you bring absolutely
everything have fun have fun to me go on
go on out there Timmy going out there
going out there this this games already
[ __ ] so you might as well [ __ ] us over
some more hay every snus Mel attacks our
noses there isn't much we can miss so
when a single brick revealing a tight
opening our senses were immediately
invaded by such terrible stretch we
should probably check out that hole and
see what the source of that smell is if
I recall it's bad how about we don't do
that how about we don't how about we
don't do that you can get used to
anything absolutely anything we decided
to ignore the whole distension anything
might happen because of it we've taken
enough risks already we ended up feeling
a bit unwell and later on we heard
something moving in the hole few hours
after that the smell was gone easy as
that one minute was all fine next we
were at our throats how this happened is
insane we need to get a grip on
ourselves we're gonna survive this let's
just sleep on it yeah I know everything
is [ __ ] and everyone hates each other
I know I am aware of this we could
barely sleep after all that arguing this
up this won't happen again all right
let's give everyone their stuff turn on
the radio why not it couldn't hurt oh
man it's this game like I don't know
what it is about this game but it hates
me this game hates me I don't know why
we're able to get a weak signal and tap
into the government's emergency
announcement service and guess what
great news
fallout outside is mostly gone it should
be much safer to travel on the surface
where is Timmy Timmy should be back if
there's anyone who can rescue us from
this health situation it's our
government you can badmouth them all you
want but that probably means you're a
naysayer or commie so let's go talk to
the government
Timmy's dead isn't he Timmy's dead we
made contact military's on the way
someone's at the door
all right let's open it up Mike come on
in buddy come on in come on come on in
apparently it's nothing bad Oh turned
out it was a nice mysterious fellow in a
weird suit he gave us some soup cans
helped us survive the next couple days
opening the hatch was a bit risky seems
it could have gave us it seems it gave
us some awful sickness Mary Jane is sick
alarm group of people outside and they
don't seem friendly okay let's just lock
the door you think you would have a
built-in lock already Oh Timmy it's
about [ __ ] time
I know you're sick but honestly who
gives a [ __ ] everyone's gonna die anyway
did you get anything we're so afraid for
Timmy but he came back and is safe with
us now we believe that our expedition to
the wasteland must have been followed by
strangers we should be more cautious
during our expedition we stumbled upon
the ruins of a familiar building our
local bank you never know what you might
find we found four cans of soup and one
can of water and a padlock and two cans
of soup lost the bug spray in the
goddamn suitcase oh god yeah Mary Jane
go into the phone
okay Dolores is gonna go out and search
for supplies with nothing on hand I
doubt she's gonna survive at least the
radiation is a little lower than it was
there's a group of bandits with a bit of
luck we can show them we're not to be
trifled with okay how about y'all go
[ __ ] yourself how about you go get bang
bang bang bang ow [ __ ] the gun exploded
uh we won the battle the bandits were no
match for us
boy we got nothing to show for it
absolutely dick did lead a show for it
gray whoo-hoo trash cans becoming bad oh
boy
giant roaches wonderful
wonderful [ __ ] wonderful
oh hello friend how are you doing down
there are you doing friend how you doing
Timmy got back turned out his hand was
infected did not healing up of God
cutting it off fine this better heal the
rest of them - this better make him not
sick okay is better at least oh come on
more bandits we just took care of them
could we throw our bullets at them how
they should really sort them out yeah ah
all right we'll signal their plane all
right okay
football ski FUBU ski just don't [ __ ]
break it I'll hide the loris what do you
bring back nothing of value great
everything was going as planned but then
the flashlights stopped working we were
lucky to get it fixed just in time to
hear the distant roar of the plane's
engines we're pretty sure the pilots saw
us let's see if they get back to us okay
silent wasteland at least one resident
who managed quite well it was a proud
looking monkey we had no idea where it
came from the zoo
maybe seemed very friendly after getting
a few Pat's on the back and playing
fetch to start following us while we
explored one of the streets our monkey
companion ran away only to come back
later carrying a can of food couldn't
open it himself but it was happy to
share with us at one point during our
expedition the monkey started making
weird sounds and thinking in front of us
with a stick a quick investigation
revealed a few bottles of water
no one even tried to open them the same
couldn't be said about those bottles of
booze lying next to them well that's
good
yay ok so now everyone needs everything
be deep boot ok good job everybody you
suck but I hate you we always wanted a
pad no matter how we have our very own
cockroach now wanna teach stuff we want
them to deeds and stay play fetch god
damn it nope we're just gonna be
swimming in bugs and if if if they
become the cockroaches then you can talk
to and I don't have the [ __ ] Boy
Scout Handbook to talk to them I'm going
to be unbelievably pissed unbelievably
fast a new cockroach roommates can be a
bit messy discussing annoy but surely
there's not the worst thing that could
have happened to us there's not much we
can do about it anyway maybe one day
we'll convince
to pay rent who's gonna go outside
absolutely why is Timmy sick again
you know what [ __ ] no one's going
outside we're gonna ride this one out
we're just gonna ride it out and
everything's fine
Timmy is sick a [ __ ] ganma found an
anonymous note whoever wrote it requests
that we send one representative to a
meeting tonight in the set location that
person must become unarmed
it's worries us but the author assures
he or she is friendly it doesn't mean to
hurt us we're going to send someone to
check it out Oh seems bad do I forget if
this is good or bad I honestly have no
idea I can't remember no let's not do
that we're not gonna do that not gonna
do that now we don't need to send
anybody not that we need anybody here
this whole thing sounds too risky we
have no way of knowing who left that
letter it might be a harmless prank or
it might be a bandit trap either way
we're staying put and waiting for the
army to come they have never once come
for me actually they have they've once
come for me and it was to lock me in and
to trap me
roaches seemed to get more organized we
have to deal them before their
civilization becomes superior to ours no
we're not gonna do that we're gonna
become infested with Roach we're
literally only gonna become roach our
time will come but for the time being
we'll have to adapt to live in this
living situation
they're here we're here let's make the
best of it they're only cockroaches
after all yeah we're not gonna do it Oh
all hands on deck there are people on
the other side of the door and they
don't seem friendly yeah they promised
us a painful death at least 17 times
there's only been five minutes since
they arrived we better prepare they'll
be forcing that door open okay lock good
thing I got that because otherwise they
just come in and sweep through
absolutely [ __ ] everything what when
Mary Jane's sickness got worse and when
we weren't able to provide her with
medicine she decided it's time to cure
whatever she had on her own she left
saying she's not coming back
we're able to fight off the bandits this
time but there's no guarantee they won't
come back we would need to be prepared
at all times that's not gonna happen at
all huh boy well this is going poorly
seven wait what is that a drawing of a
lady
this is drawing of a lady with a boot is
that literally a drawing with a lady
with a boot or a lady with an axe I'm
not 100% sure or lady strangling a
penguin
oh boy nope nah cockroaches are just
gonna be here forever that's that's what
we do that's how we do it that's what we
okay everyone's sing great everyone's
sick
wonderful wonderful although they're a
big glowing we're pretty sure they
spread diseases we have no means of
fighting those damn roaches best get
used to the situation better the roaches
than bandits or commies no oh God a band
of Raiders are at our doorstep we either
yield or fight back there's no middle
ground here oh no oh no no oh do they
take Timmy we watch helplessly as those
cruel thugs - Timmy out of the shelter
we open someday oh no oh no oh no oh no
the bandits are so horrendous military
communication is through the radio was
sure it was signal to evacuate out of
here but turns they need our help you
chop down a tree or two I can't do that
I don't have what I need I don't have
that just kill me mr. bent end it oh
just end it
the Raiders are back oh oh oh
they took Delores ah god damn it they
took Delores oh [ __ ] well that's that
good I did show but show fours and my
fing up well plenty of food and water
for him oh no it's the letter I don't
think I don't think so if I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die alone in my shelter
without my family oh boy well bandits
are at the door again of course they're
at the door again why wouldn't I yep I'm
[ __ ] dead they shot me in my face
good [ __ ] god
we thought these bandits would just kill
us all but instead they grabbed Ted and
took him away at gunpoint
we have nothing bad happened to him well
technically maybe I'm not dead maybe I
just got sold as a slave that's great oh
[ __ ]
oh well that went about as much as I
expected to be I can't win it this one
no matter how good I think I'm going no
matter how well I think I'm doing I will
always fail and that is just the life
that I live in this game but either way
thank you all so much for watching I
don't think I'm ever gonna win with this
game but there's more DLC on the way so
maybe I'll try it again when that new
DLC comes out but until then I am left
to my own devices and I'm left alone and
scared with all my family members being
grabbed up by bandits so thank you again
everybody for watching and if you got
any tips or tricks for me write them
down in the comments below so thanks
again and as always I'll see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]